whenever i'm looking at a camera
especially when i'm you know recording a
video and so forth the camera for me is
like looking into the eyes of a person
and so i visually think about imagine
i'm doing this presentation
and i'm talking to one person it's
actually not even a huge audience it's
like i'm talking to one person and right
now i'm looking at the camera like
directly down the middle of the lens
and i'm talking to that one person and
you know what i'm thinking about
i'm thinking about the difficulties that
you're going through i'm thinking about
the challenges that you're facing i'm
thinking about
happening to you know get enough money
to go to the next level in your business
or hiring your first staff member i'm
thinking about the difficulties of that
that you're facing and when i'm speaking
even if i'm not
mentioning those things i'm thinking
about who you are as a person
welcome to the think media podcast my
name is heather torres i'm the host of
this show and here we want to help you
grow your youtube influence and then
turn that youtube influence into a high
income and high impact online business
and if you're brand new to this podcast
we release a new episode every single
tuesday and for those over on the
youtube channel we have bonus shows just
for you so make sure you are subscribed
wherever you like to consume your
podcast on and if you are commuting in
the car walking the dog doing the dishes
i want to thank you for putting us in
your ears and being a part and letting
us be a part of your journey here as
you're growing your youtube influence
now today we get to have a special guest
on the show and today's episode is
brought to you by think
infusionselling.com you'll learn more
about that during today's episode but
it's all about storytelling this is one
of the topics that i love so much
because as a content creator we want to
be sharing our stories because when you
share your stories people get to know
like and trust you they become a part of
what you're doing they see what impact
you're trying to make in the world or
what impact you're not trying to make in
the world when you start sharing your
signature story so we have our special
guest colin boyd on the podcast today
and you're gonna learn all about how to
figure out what your story is i remember
when i started uh sharing content on
youtube i didn't really know what parts
to share and you know how deep i wanted
to go and sharing my personal journey as
an entrepreneur and as a content creator
but colin's going to help you figure out
what your personal story is what your
signature story is you're also going to
learn why it's important to be sharing
this story as you're creating content
and you're going to learn the three
secret ingredients to your signature
story i cannot wait for us to get into
today's featured content so let's jump
into today's conversation
[Music]
welcome back to the think media podcast
i am fired up for today's episode with
colin boyd and we're going to be talking
about the three
secrets
for your signature story and how that
will help you connect with your audience
more you can apply this to videos
webinars your courses your content and
colin is really a communications expert
and he's going to help us get more
confident on camera if you ever have the
nerves before recording he's going to
talk about how to calm those he's got
all kinds of strategies that we can
apply but if you're just meeting colin
he's a husband and a dad he's been
running his own business for over eight
years in coaching training keynote
speaking around the world for large
corporations and organizations and he
really helps experts speakers and
consultants to increase their influence
and leverage their passion
into a successful business colin and his
wife sarah are personal friends and
we've actually been a part of a kind of
a business group together for uh over a
year now and so uh his content has
personally helped me in fact
our youtube domination framework is a
tension framework that i actually
learned from colin and that framework
has not only served our community and
served you the think media podcast but
we've
published that in a few different videos
that's now responsible for hundreds of
thousands of views so i encourage you to
buckle your seatbelt for this entire
podcast because there's going to be a
lot of juicy content that you can apply
to grow your youtube channel your
business and your brand on line but with
that colin welcome to the podcast hey
great to be here sean
um i'm fired up to dive into um
specifically why is a signature story
important what if you feel like you
don't have a story what are the three
secret ingredients but if people are
just meeting you what is your story in a
nutshell
so for me uh i don't know about you but
i know for me when i first started uh my
coaching business uh i i didn't i didn't
have any clients like so i didn't you
know like i had this dream this desire
to make a difference in the world and
you know i had that tension internally
of uh i've basically you know there's
there's no one to serve no one to help
and so what happened was for me
personally i'm sitting in front of my my
old laptop with my mouse pad and all
that sort of stuff i'm looking at my
calendar no clients on i get i get a
phone call
from uh on my landline if you remember
those uh and i pick it up and it's a
buddy and he goes hey man i've got a
presentation coming up and it's free so
you you know not getting paid for it uh
but i think it might be good and he and
he also says to me he said i got given
it from another person and that they
didn't want to do it and then he gave it
to me and he goes and i just don't want
to do it he goes dirk and you do it and
so it's a real hot lead right like super
hot lead
um no one wants it so i i end up working
my myself up to that place of going okay
i'm gonna do it like this was my first
like ever presentation you could say
and i remember the night of it i headed
into it and it was literally a dark and
stormy night i'm so nervous my hands are
sweating the event organizer runs up to
me and he's like colin like you wouldn't
believe this
this is the biggest event we've ever
held we've got like record numbers he
said there's 137 people here and we're
just so excited to hear your
presentation now now for me
this is bad news
because
it just felt like i was just going to
look like an idiot in front of more
people
and so
what happened was i got up i i presented
and at the end i made an offer now what
i didn't realize was was the offer i
made was actually an irresistible offer
which we can talk about today as well
and and what happened was out of 137
people 125 of them gave me their
personal details i followed up did a
whole bunch of coaching because at the
time i was selling coaching
and i ended up signing a full deck of
coaching clients so i went from zero
coaching clients i was kind of like a
half coaching client uh up to it was
like 12 13 full-time coaching clients
and then hp called me four days later
and said hey would you come and speak at
our global conference and i ended up
speaking for hp for over 10 years
and so what was crazy
was that that literally in one
presentation and obviously that was a
live presentation and now that can be
amplified onto virtual stages and
virtual events and challenges and all
that sort of stuff now
but at the time that one presentation
literally took me from kind of zero to
hero in my own mind of going you know i
had nothing in my business
and it launched my business in one
experience and so the revelation i had
back then was just the power of speaking
and the power of using a vehicle um and
obviously this is a stage in itself
right now and for me just to be clear a
stage for me
is any visual and verbal platform where
you're connecting with a leveraged
audience so for me when i
my people don't come to me to learn how
to do a podcast right even though you
can use a lot of the strategies for me a
stage is any sort of visual and verbal
experience that you have with a
leveraged leveraged audience and so the
big idea was this for me was that like
literally in one presentation you can
you can have a breakthrough in your
business
that's amazing and um i'm excited in
part two kind of as we get towards the
end of this uh you know to talk about
how we can power up our challenges our
webinars of course everyone listening
here is interested in video um as well
as really this being a video podcast and
i think video podcasting is really the
future as well youtube is investing
and probably going to have some podcast
integration kind of a syndication maybe
even a you know rss feed or whatever i
think that's all going to happen on the
platform as well but i want to dive into
just one nuance and i would love to blow
it up more into like how this can lead
to us making more money selling around
our offers but specifically this idea of
a signature story um one of the
challenges on youtube is that you can
create content that's also intent based
or search based and people might come by
you might get some views you might even
generate some income through adsense or
affiliate marketing but if you don't
really connect with your audience they
also might just pass through but one of
the ways we can really connect with an
audience is is by telling story however
i'm sure there's kind of objections like
does somebody really care if i'm just
teaching something to hear my life's
story for three hours starting at my
date of birth you know
totally and and there's it's it's also
kind of a buzz word i've learned people
like oh man you you got to just tell
your story like you know you just really
got to tap into the power of story like
you know the people who get it did you
hear that guy he's a story expert what
do you even mean like what are we
talking about like i mean it's it is
kind of he wrote a book on storytelling
you're like okay i mean what like am i a
fiction author now like what you know
so i'm just kind of curious specifically
for thought leaders experts speakers
personal brands the listeners of this
very video podcast
why is sharing our story important as it
pertains to basically public speaking
this visual communication format yeah
yeah and i would say that when you said
you know this is a video podcast for me
this is a stage so it has those elements
in there and so like first off like
that's awesome um story your story is
fascinating first of all
no one cares about your story
other than maybe your mum
your mum probably cares but but no one
really cares about your story and so
when you say you know why would someone
want to listen to your story you know
they probably don't want to
and that's the big distinction i want to
bring out here
is that when you tell your story
you have to design it so that when the
audience hears it
yeah they hear they hear your story but
they actually hear their story
and so what that means
is that when you're telling your story
you need to bring out the vulnerability
the difficulty the challenge the
internal resistance the internal desires
the journey that you went on in a way
where the audience goes
this is like they the audience will go
you know what maybe i haven't been
through that exact experience but
they'll go i've got those desires i've
got those challenges i've got i want to
make a difference in my world and so
when you tell your story
your story shouldn't be
your origin story so you shouldn't start
with you know i was born in for me i was
actually born in canada i was born in
canada in 1981 and i moved to australia
when i was two and i grew up on the
beaches and you know and my mom you know
showed me this like like no one cares
about that story right
the story you have to tell is the story
that actually imparts
the most important belief that your
audience
needs to believe in order to commit to
themselves
in the area that you can help them with
now i just said a lot there
and this is going to come back to one of
the three secrets that we're going to
get to
but to clarify
no one cares about your story and so
when you think about i don't want to
tell my story don't worry about that
because when you design it right your
story is actually their story and so
that's one of the first frames i think
you need to view your story through
i love it and and specifically
you know we've had some other great
guests on the podcast uh brock johnson
johnson have taught a lot on
storytelling and
brock johnson for example has a book
where he tries to capture a lot of
stories that could be illustrations
for
uh to make a certain point and in some
cases it might just be a funny story
that illustrates one thing there might
be a particular story from your life
that could make a connection that might
illustrate one point
of your offer um and and so
as we build out depth
and if you will curriculum and content
in our own personal brands we eventually
might have multiple stories but here
we're talking about
a signature story what do you mean
specifically by that term yeah signature
i need to define this so
i know we kind of frame this as your
signature story but i have a specific
take on it and so i don't usually call
it like initially i call it signature
story because that's what people connect
with and understand with
but what i'm talking about is what's
called a conversion story
and it converts the difference between a
signature story and a conversion story
is that a signature story is a lot of
the time designed to talk about who you
are where you came from your journey
into where you got there and it's kind
of like an origin experience
where a conversion story
in the frame of a signature story a
conversion story is actually the story
that when and when someone asks you to
share your story you don't go back to
your origin and where you grew up and
all that sort of stuff you actually tell
the experience
that
amplifies
and showcases
the most important belief that the
audience must have
in order for the audience to commit in
the area that you can help them with
so if we go back to you know when sean
asked me right in the start he said hey
you know tell me your story tell me your
signature story i didn't say you know i
grew up in australia on the beaches and
we moved to america four years ago and
i started my coaching bus like i didn't
tell that story right i told a story of
where i was sitting struggling with my
business
and didn't know where to go didn't know
what to do and i had an opportunity come
up that was like given to me and then it
literally changed my life and that was a
speaking opportunity now i help people
to speak more effectively on live and
virtual stages like video et cetera
right so that is the core area that i
help them with so whenever someone asks
me to tell me tell them my story i don't
tell the whole story i tell them the
conversion story and so that's what
we're talking about today and i think
every expert
youtube expert video expert like there
needs to be some sort of conversion
story not just your origin story because
that's the thing that's going to move
the audience towards the offer and
that's what i'm obsessed with is helping
your content move the audience towards
your offer not just the audience to go
like oh that's a cool story
powerful and and as you were opening you
were talking about uh things that i'm
sure we can all relate to in the think
media podcast community i'm feeling fear
the numbers of attendees are going up
and now i'm nervous and and listening to
this podcast right now people want to go
live but if too many people show up oh
oh wait who are these people self-doubt
palms are sweaty needs weak mom's
spaghetti i mean you know
stuff's happening like like we can
relate to that and and you're now also
you've built this successful business
you've you've got these successful
products but it's also people can't
relate to your success until they hear
your struggle
and i could see myself in that same
story maybe confident to speak on stage
now but terrified in the past or it
depends on what stage it is and i'm
still experiencing the butterflies or
and so very powerful and and the
transformation because for any of us
most of us are helping people we on
the goal is to what problem do you solve
and who do you help who do you help and
what problem do you help them solve on
our youtube channel especially in that
more education angle and niche
and we're helping
our avatar we're helping our
ideal viewer is usually ourself a couple
years ago
and a couple of years ago we're stuck
we're struggling we're nervous we're
maybe getting some results and we get
into that emotion so
that i like this we're really talking
about the three secret ingredients of a
conversion story yeah so let's jump into
those what's the first ingredient yeah
so the first ingredient
is uh is challenge and you touched on
that before where you were talking about
you know the the difficulty the sweaty
palms the struggling to get clients uh
because no one cares how good you are
until they know
that you were like them at some point
and so
the the first part of any sort of
conversion story
is you you have to start in a place of
difficulty and challenge now sometimes
people come to me and say colin but i've
got to be natural at this like they
might say i'm i've always had a natural
skill and that might may not be you but
if you've got that thought
i still want to encourage you that this
pro there probably was a skill
development journey and some self-doubt
or difficulty that you had or some
difficult moments
that you can bring out and so the first
part of of a of the conversion story
you know your signature story but you
get it now right the conversion story
is that the audience has to connect with
you
they have to answer that question of
they have to say oh my gosh i'm like you
now it's not do you look like them have
you gone through the same experience the
way you do this is you actually do it
from an internal perspective you do it
from and i usually amplify the tension
that you're experiencing internally
during the journey of difficulty and
challenge in your in your story
and so that's the desires that you had
the impact you wanted to make but the
tension the fears the doubts the anxiety
all that sort of stuff and so the first
piece is the is the challenge and so
sean i don't know if you want to talk to
that at all um for you before we get
into the second piece
well 100 and i think what
a large majority of our community
connects to
um in my story was going back to 2009
and my story is pretty dramatic and i
want to touch on this
in a second as somebody might ask well i
don't know if my story is that good or i
don't know if my story is that dramatic
but when i go back to
2009 my wife almost dies
the housing bubble crashed
we were both working multiple jobs but
i'm working in ministry and she's
actually the bigger breadwinner but now
her health's under attack
and
not only that our church falls apart
senior leaders steal some money
and it's at
massive challenge crisis fear six
hundred thousand dollars in debt
that a new fire is lit in my heart
to
find a way to provide for my family
and
at that same time i'm in the hospital by
my wife's side for six days i actually
not only am i praying god what am i
gonna do and i feel like man i really
gotta step up man up as a leader i'm now
looking for answers and and i go to
barnes noble across the street from the
hospital there's a success magazine and
there's a cd in the middle of the
magazine
and it's
um
the key interview back when there were
cds was gary vaynerchuk talking about
his new book crush it why now is the
time to cash in on your passion and um i
read that while i'm in the hospital and
i start thinking okay i've already been
doing videos since 2003 i started a
channel for my church on youtube i've
been studying affiliate marketing and
all this stuff and i'm getting a little
bit of clarity like man i got to crush
it now i don't know what i'm supposed to
do and i wander for the next multiple
years
but that was really that genesis
moment that that set up set us on the
trajectory to where we are today and
that story comes up a lot or is woven
into our various you know content um and
so
that's that's that challenge piece right
and and youtube was also the very
vehicle
to
transport us uh to financial freedom as
well as
growing our business and initially even
helping other clients and and being able
to sell freelance services around
youtube and all the different things so
am i on the right track with dude
i love that and and and what can be cool
imagine like describing the moment of
where you're sitting next to your wife
holding her hand
and you're looking at her she's she's
helpless she's sick and and what that
feeling was like internally as a husband
as a provider as a however you want to
see that and that tension like
what could be cool is and i love the
visuals of that picking up that magazine
so like spending that time in the
visuals
and picturing those things and you
actually like go back and relive that
experience because when you feel it when
you relive it the audience i don't care
whether they're on video or they're on a
live stage it doesn't matter the
audience
instantly feels the energetic change in
you when when you relive that experience
and so
you know
their audience may not have had that
experience they may not have had you
know they may not go to church they may
they may not have had you know that
experience like that or their wife go
through some of that but what they have
experienced is the hardship that the
feeling that comes out and so all of a
sudden you go from being the youtube
guru to being oh my gosh sean's just
like me
and and so all of a sudden they're going
to start to go wow now
now i'm on this journey with him and
maybe i could do something like him as
well
and so a couple questions on that to
drill a little deeper on this challenge
the first is i want to encourage
listeners
even though
i would say a year after this happened
three years after this happened five
years after this happened
i didn't
even really perceive the power of story
in my own life
it wasn't until learning some of these
things and even i think trauma too
sometimes disconnects you you like it's
you have to kind of go back and mine out
some of those details and i love the
advice that i know we're all benefiting
from right now
getting in there feeling it going back
there personally so even though i've
been crafting this story as well i think
that's one of the keys crafting it
kind of thinking about okay there's even
things i remember or sometimes
people on the fake media team i'll talk
about when i really get into it like
you know we rushed first to the everett
community hospital she got stabilized
and then i followed the ambulance you
know lights spinning from everett to
seattle and our honda civic down you
know questioning on the drive and so so
and i and i had to like piece by piece
kind of re-piece the story together like
it all happened but you could just get
up and like you said you could say it
dry not really go there there'll be
levels to crafting the story but here's
my question before we get into the next
two tips
maybe a lot of listeners are thinking i
don't i mean that one's that's that's
pretty good i mean it's a pretty i mean
i you know we couldn't plan that that's
a pretty
it's dramatic it makes for
you know if it was made right into a
film it'd be pretty interesting or
rather a a 30-minute 60 minute special
or something or an hour i suppose you
know whatever like and they just go okay
well i'm talking about gardening you
know on youtube
what is
i don't you know i didn't have much
what would you encourage someone who's
doubting that they have a conversion
story or having trouble seeing that for
themselves yeah well i mean in the
context of of challenge that we're
talking about right now for me um all
you just need to do is just find a
moment in your life of of real
difficulty a moment in your life that
kind of that woke you up
and said i need to
make a decision
i need to change the way that i'm living
i need to take more responsibility i
need to take more risk
any sort of experience and that could
have been a relation like a broken
relationship that could have been just a
moment when you were sitting in a hotel
room and just you know down on your luck
and
and feeling sorry for yourself and and
just feeling stuck you know like i think
everyone has had one of those moments
and if you haven't then you're probably
not human and so
one of the challenges is having the
courage to
look at the reality and go like when was
some of the most difficult moments of my
life now they may or may not be a part
of your conversion story but i think
it's really powerful to do that exercise
to start there
because usually it's some of those
moments
that were the catalyst of where you made
the decision to make a change in your
life so for you sean
you know you went through that moment
but obviously
you know there may or may not have been
a like an absolute like oh my gosh i'm
just going to go all in on youtube like
it probably was an evolutionary journey
but when you tell your conversion story
i would i would be clear on
that that there was an area of your life
that you knew had huge potential and it
was video and you were using the
platform of youtube and and and so you
do want to clearly link it but a lot of
the times during the actual experience
it's not as clear but obviously if you
have to link
what your offer is and what you help
people with with your signature story
and that is part of the crafting
crafting of the signature story and so
and this is going to make more sense as
we get into step two and three
of what i'm talking about here
let's go there what's step number two
so the yes so like i said the first
one's challenge
the the second core piece
is um is credibility and so what most
people think is that their signature
story is about proving to the audience
that they are good at what they do and
so
what will tend to happen is
they will focus on you know what their
results are or
what their accolades are or something
like that but what what's beautiful here
in this balance of what you watch this
happen is when you start in challenge
and vulnerability the audience goes
you're like me
i get you
and and you've been through the
difficulty it's like we're on the same
page and then you talk about that
decision moment that journey that you
went on and sure there might have been
some struggle and so forth all the way
through to your breakthrough moment and
remember the breakthrough moment is
built around we're about to get into it
the third element in a second but the
breakthrough moment or the breakthrough
experience
the credibility
is more about showing that the vehicle
that you chose which is the thing that
you help people with
enabled you to create the credibility
and the results that you always wanted
so in other words it's the it's the
victory and so the the two the first two
elements i kind of say like a venn
diagram right there's three three
you know circles and so the first circle
is challenge and vulnerability
the second circle is credibility and the
victory that you experience now
obviously there's a journey that you can
go into now you don't have to go into
all the details but you might find one
moment of where you had a breakthrough
in that journey towards getting the
credibility and what's fascinating
is that if you can connect with your
audience through the challenge the
vulnerability
and then take them on a bit of a journey
of the results that you've got and you
actually don't even have to spend too
much time on your credibility and it
could be literally just like you know
we've got this many youtube but at the
end we've got this many youtube
followers we've got this many so and so
we've you know we've achieved this in
our business and we have a desire and a
passion to create this
like people will be on board with you
because remember the goal of your
signature story is to not prove
that you are good enough
to teach them
that will happen naturally um as you
actually share your content now
obviously part of it is
but the purpose of your signature stor a
signature story when it becomes a
conversion story is actually related to
the third element
and the third element
is that the whole signature story
is aligned with your core
idea or your core premise and your core
premise
is essentially the one idea that you
want your audience to have a revelation
of
so that they can see that there's a
pathway to achieving what they want in
their life
and so for you sean i'm just going to
take a guess like the core premise could
be
that using
video
through the vehicle of a vehicle of
youtube you may or may not even include
youtube like video is like the core one
and then youtube is the mechanism it's
like using video is the fastest most
effective way to reach your audience and
create the clients that you've always
wanted like i'm just making this up
right so is it something like that your
call premise your core id
100 and i think yeah video would be the
more macro but certainly
over what we've done um in the last
decade it would be youtube but it would
also kind of be like our proprietary
process which would be search based or
intent-based content on youtube
connected to if you go really deep
affiliate marketing but basically
search-based content because it was what
we really believe now over 10 000 people
in our video ranking academy community
that is a unique approach to youtube as
well and it was the approach as i
started to realize back then youtube is
a search engine i started to connect
that to even specific videos related to
affiliate marketing
youtube being free being able to be an
affiliate being free and if i started i
i had i had the light bulb tested the
theory
and it became the very vehicle that
helped us climb out of debt climb you
know start paying medical bills start
doing all these different things and so
uh absolutely you could say you could
summarize it as video you could
summarize it as youtube but even as we
tap into you i suppose a unique selling
position
you know other there's different
approaches to youtube yeah but our
proprietary process or our angle on
youtube itself is like hey if you use it
in this particular way and you have the
right
profitable niche
that it that people are actually looking
for that there's an actual audience for
that now now you could create a vehicle
to make
an extra grand a month an extra five
grand a month the next you know make it
a six-figure business scale it into a
seven-figure media empire um and so
absolutely one hundred percent so
that's the flow on and so for me what i
want to get with you with your listeners
is that is which which i know you've
done which is boiling it down to that
really simple statement of like that you
know maybe it's that through youtube
youtube search based practices is the
most effective way to get x whatever
they want right for me it is
it is crafting an irresistible
presentation using infusion selling
is the most effective way to get a
breakthrough in your business fast
and so
my core premise is all around one
presentation that might be a webinar
that you design and then you scale that
up or it might be a challenge you design
you scale that up and so
my core premise is around
speaking right your core premise is
around youtube and both of them are
right what's cool about core premises
is that there's not like oh i've won if
you've got one core premise then the
other core premise isn't right no
your job as a content creator is to help
your audience in the experience that
they have whether it be on a podcast or
whether it be on a on a speaking
engagement or a webinar is to build the
beliefs that they need around the core
premise that you help them with to show
them that hey if this is
the v if this is the outcome that you
want and you resonate with me and the
vehicle that i do it with
then i'm the guy i'm the girl who can
help you achieve that
super super strong and 100
listening to this there's
especially if you will in the personal
development or
youtube expert influencer space
um
there's a lot of core premises needed
you know people ask what's the key to
success and it's really not a key it's
actually a combination like a
combination lock
certainly there's different ingredients
you want to add in there
i mean mastering communication crafting
your signature story learning infusion
selling as you're saying uh and and a
lot of our community sometimes finds
themselves there's kind of two big
groups there's there's the group that's
a small business owner um they already
have an offer there's the course
creators um and they're already you know
crushing it and or wanting to crush it
they've created those things and they're
wanting to use youtube as a vehicle to
promote and amplify what they're already
doing and then there's kind of about the
other group who sort of their first
tiptoe into things was like i want to do
youtube like in and of itself like they
kind of say
you know they did a survey of like 13 to
15 year olds or whatever and like the
majority of them more than wanting to be
an astronaut want to be a youtuber
there's an awareness that the creator
economy is a real thing in and of itself
whether monetization patreon brand deals
but once you get into that we would then
begin to unpack that's why we want to
introduce our community to people like
you because we really believe eventually
you need to create something to sell
eventually you should package what you
know
in an online course eventually you need
to create
an irresistible offer eventually even as
you can tap into a lot of income streams
like affiliate marketing and adsense you
don't want to be dependent on youtube
for your revenue or amazon affiliate
program or whatever for your revenue you
need to create something of your own
and actually eventually sell that which
would mean we need to also learn how to
sell so to your point and as you know
you collaborate with all kinds of people
a lot of core premises
but i like this because once you really
distill down your brand
you got it would you would you say you
need to niche down i mean we we know you
now as the
infusion selling guy you're specifically
going to help us masters public speaking
on video in challenges and stages
physically as that returns in as well
uh but unto selling an offer not just to
speak to entertain but actually to build
a business
um and and then i'm the youtube guy and
so for the listeners
that maybe maybe there's a lot of light
bulbs going on but there's maybe also
even some like okay shoot
i don't have anything to sell or i'm not
even sure what my core premise is
how do you kind of zero in on niching
down and figuring out your core premise
or maybe we have a lot of real estate
agents or financial professionals so
they kind of maybe know what it is they
know what their business is and they
know they want clients
but they're like i don't know i mean how
do i get a core premise that's unique in
the market yeah
so
i think first of all you need to start
with just working out what you think
your core premise is and so for me you
know there are multiple versions of my
core premise but one of the clearest
ones is is i'll say to my audience
that that you are one irresistible
presentation away from the breakthrough
you've been looking for in your business
and then i you know obviously i'll go
into all the evidence and all the
different reasons why that's true and so
forth but
one way to describe it and this doesn't
work for everyone um but it could work
for you it's like you were one
youtube channel away from
creating the business and the dreams
you've always desired
right or it could be so that's one
version is like you are one x away from
getting the result that you desired
another way to do it is is simply to
just go
you say what the vehicle is what you
help people with now when i say the
vehicle the vehicle
is either the unique methodology
or it's just the platform that you use
so if you're a real estate agent it
could literally be a certain type of
property so it could be like positive
cash flow property
is the most effective way to scale your
your income and create the security
you've always wanted in your in your
life right and so that's not super
unique but at least it's clear
and so i think what you know before we
even get into like being unique and all
unique selling mechanisms and so forth
the first thing people need to do is
they just need to get clear on what the
vehicle is that they help people with
and that doesn't have to be unique
because think about it like this
is that as long as the audience can
clearly see
that that vehicle will help them and
they're in the vicinity of your
your content and they're experiencing it
then most probably
you're going to be the person that they
go to to help to create the result that
you help them with right now obviously
the 2.0 version of that is having some
unique methodologies so for me i teach
people to sell from a stage from a
virtual stage or a live stage
a unique methodology that i have is
called infusion selling and and in the
context of today so this makes sense
um infusion selling is essentially the
ability to be able to speak and sell at
the same time so most people try to like
speak they do content and then they
whack a cell on the end and it just
feels super awkward what i teach is you
speak and sell at the same time so they
come together right and
signature story
is one of the nine infusion selling
strategies so we're going i'm literally
giving you one of them today
infusion selling uh the signature story
process right and so
the context of this coming back to core
premise is i think for your listeners is
to first of all to just go
what's a clear statement of the vehicle
i help them with that might be property
investment that might be youtube that
might be content creation whatever it is
and link that to the result that the
audience wants so start with that and
then we then you can eventually get into
unique selling propositions and
methodologies and so forth
beautiful well in just a second we're
going to get into
a couple practical tips too for like
calming our nerves for getting on camera
being more confident
on camera but i want to unpack um
some of the other things inside of this
and colin and i spoke before i was
curious if he had anything if you want
to go deeper with him specifically in
signature story as well as the other
areas he teaches related to infusion
selling and you actually just put
together an offer
that will help you if you're interested
you can check it out of course in the
show notes or in our youtube description
or just go to think infusionselling.com
and uh i love colin stuff again uh by
taking his methodologies his frameworks
and applying them to webinars or
speeches i've done or specifically
youtube videos i mentioned just one
framework that he shared with me has led
to hundreds of thousands of views and
really helped bring clarity to
our community um and so
colin what are some of the other i mean
we can't get into them but what are the
a few of the other nine total infusion
selling strategies yeah totally so um
so
to go before we go through this
the reason why you would want to learn
infusion selling is if you're creating
content at the moment and you're getting
lots of likes and comments and stuff
like that but it's not leading to sales
and you're also the type of person who
doesn't like to
be super pushy with your selling so you
like creating that real magnetic pull in
your communication
because the goal of it is that at the
end of any presentation that you give or
video you know youtube video whatever it
is that they would go oh my gosh i just
need what that person has like i need
the system right so that's what infusion
selling does and so infusion selling is
nine strategies let me give you another
one so another one
that we use with infusion selling is
what what i call micro decisions
and micro decisions is a methodology
where throughout a video throughout a
webinar throughout a challenge
you're actually setting up really
strategic decision points
throughout your presentation so that
you don't just wait till the end what
most people do is they just present a
whole bunch of content right like open
up the fire hose it's like let me give
you everything every step i've got every
like and people audience like this is
awesome like and they're also like and
i'm completely overwhelmed and i don't
know what to do first right and so
they're completely overwhelmed and then
you get to the end and you're like and
if you like this buy it you know like
you can buy my stuff
and so what happens is you don't teach
the audience
to actually
build their decision making muscle
because at the core of it
a presentation or a video that sells
is a video that moves an audience to
make a decision that that's it like that
is literally
what i teach is like helping people to
move their audience to make a decision
right
and
micro decisions
where you strategically ask the audience
to make decisions to commit to
themselves to commit to their content
throughout
or commit to themselves and commit to
the content that you're talking about
throughout the presentation so you might
have five or six
small decisions that you're asking the
audience to make they could be writing
comments and so forth throughout the
presentation so that when you reveal
your offer when you actually move into
your pitch because you will have to
share an offer at some point right if
you want to have a business
um when you move into your pitch it's
just the next decision and they've
already been it's kind of like they've
already been working out at the gym
and they're they're used to lifting the
weights and then they're like okay i've
made lots of decisions around this
already
am i ready for the big decision which is
joining your program and that's when
truly that's when you can really help
them it's like you know with sean like
like th this content is really valuable
but but if if you want to really learn
youtube like really learn it and
really see results you got to join his
course like like that is that's where
like the full breadth of the
transformation is right and i know for
me it's kind of like this an example is
um i'm australian you can hear you can
hear my strain accent
for three years i tried
to move to the u.s right so what that
means is like i'm on youtube i'm sorry
how does australians move to the us i'm
talking to people i'm taking them out
for coffee
i'm picking their brains
i am
by the end of it i'm more confused on
how to move to america than i was at the
start right because i'm my kids call it
kerfuffling around i'm like kerfuffling
around i'm not making any decisions and
so what happened was is eventually i got
to the point i said am i really going to
do this and i said yes and we hired an
international lawyer an immigration
consultant an international tax
accountant and literally within six
months my feet hit american soil and
we've been here for just over four years
and so what's crazy was i fuffeld around
for three years because i wasn't making
any decisions
and then within six months i'd set up
everything we've moved our family with
two little kids and our whole life had
changed and that's the power of making a
decision and for me it was putting money
down it was making a commitment and so
the transformation will actually or the
transaction of them joining your program
is actually and which is a decision is
actually part of their transformation
that they will see and create results
super strong and so if you want to learn
more micro decisions signature story and
even see the details on uh on the other
ones inside of the infusion selling
system
think
infusionselling.com if you're
specifically if you already have an
offer if you have a course
if you have clients or services
already built then this would be a
really no-brainer for you i'm pumped to
see that call and put together something
super affordable and you can immediately
apply these things and they'll start
working uh in the environment that you
already have if you haven't created
those things yet uh definitely check it
out as well because this kind of
thinking is the kind of information i
wish i had when i was first getting into
this it actually makes me think of
someone in our community right now who
actually they wanted to build out their
information in a course and they
finished it they put it inside
they their expertise is in photography
they have a kind of a unique way of
doing it that's a fast workflow getting
everything done
and they package all their stuff
together uploaded it to thinkific
got it going uploaded logo got the price
out there
even shared it on a decent
not huge but not small social media
following
and crickets was just talking to this
individual zero sales
and this kind of can happen a lot you
have an offer but
it's not quite enough you got to make
those connections and so learning how to
weave some of these things in and talk
to this individual this this it would be
perfect for that so if you have an ebook
or like a course or something um this is
a skill set that is kind of under taught
so i'm super glad that colin is sharing
this with us today uh if you want to
learn a little bit more that is in
show notes again as we said uh wherever
you're listening or watching or think
infusionselling.com and you can see all
the details and a really cool
uh super affordable to offer that i
think you'll love but colin i want to
ask you
specifically now uh on your expertise i
saw a video on your youtube channel
how to be more confident when speaking
but you called it
sexy confidence
um i'm curious you know if we want to
tap into maybe just not only getting
calming our nerves maybe that's the
starting point but tapping into
our sweet spot our sweetness like
there's always something powerful when
hey someone's kind of like 101 they
overcome the initial nerves you're like
yeah they presented the information
effectively and then there's somebody
who comes together comes across and they
don't need to be like somebody else they
just kind of have that magic and that's
one of the things you help people
develop what are just some practical
things as we land the plane today on uh
on just kind of being more confident
when speaking on video
i love video and i've been speaking on
video for many years uh obviously i
don't i don't teach it like you um but
for me video is just beautiful and and
whenever i'm looking at a camera
uh especially when i'm you know
recording a video and so forth the
camera for me is like looking into the
eyes of a person
and so i visually think about imagine
i'm doing this presentation
and i'm talking to one person it's
actually not even a huge audience it's
like i'm talking to one person and right
now i'm looking at the camera like
directly down the middle of the lens
and i'm talking to that one person and
you know what i'm thinking about
i'm thinking about the difficulties that
you're going through i'm thinking about
the challenges that you're facing i'm
thinking about
happening to you know get enough money
to go to the next level in your business
or hiring your first staff member i'm
thinking about the difficulties of that
that you're facing and when i'm speaking
even if i'm not
mentioning those things i'm thinking
about who you are as a person and so i
look at the camera and it's not a it's
not a camera because whenever i look at
a camera
it can feel
like uh like technical right it's a
piece of technical equipment
no when you look at a camera that's a
human being and the more you can
experience that and feel that and think
about your perfect customer imagine
you're talking having an intimate
conversation with them when you're on
camera with them it will change the game
about how you show up on camera and so
for me it's more about you know i'm not
great with all the technical side of
things but the stage presence
is is like you really need to see it as
you're talking to a person and if you
watch the greatest youtubers the
greatest video presenters that's what
they do like it's it's like as if
they're talking to you right and they
they change their how they how how
they're moving and so forth and they're
talking to the the camera in a way that
you're a human being
uh
that's that's what that's that's the
first frame
from from a practical perspective
for me it all a lot of it a lot of it
comes down to your thinking and what you
do with your physiology and so when i
say your thinking is if you're coming
into doing a video or something like
that or presentation
and you're telling yourself things like
uh they're going to hate this they're
going to
or asking questions like will they even
like my content or what will they think
of me like you're asking yourself really
poor quality questions or having a poor
quality conversation with yourself
your psychology will instantly affect
how you feel and essentially how you
show up and so for me i'm i'm ruthless
with my thinking coming into a webinar
or a presentation or a video series or
something like that and so i'm really
conscious i even physically write down
what i believe about myself i'll say i'm
i am a transformational coach i'm a
world-class trainer and speaker i'm a
leader of market leaders i like write
this stuff down and i get clear on what
i believe about myself coming into my
presentations and so that's like
psychologically and one last tip is
physiologically what's really cool is is
literally to like hold your shoulders up
like even right now if you're watching
this video sit up hold your shoulders up
put a smile on your face just because it
feels good right um stand up straight
take a deep breath in and notice the air
going through your nostrils do it right
now just take a deep breath and notice
the air going through your nostrils
wiggle your toes and feel feel how your
toes feel in your shoes right take a
deep breath in through your nostrils the
goal is to be physiologically strong
but mentally present
so not mentally thinking about every
single thing you're going to say is to
be actually mentally present
and so you should have rehearsed what
you're going to say beforehand
and when you get on on screen you might
have a prompter or things like that
personally i don't love prompters i'll
have like bullet points that i might
want to hit and that's it
um but it's like you want to be present
because remember you're you're not
you're not doing a reading a reading is
what you do for kids you're talking to
adults they want to hear you though and
experience you they want to have a
conversation with you and so when you do
these things you're going to feel better
you're going to show up as the bigger
version of yourself and you're going to
connect with your audience like never
before
man i was right there with you my
posture just corrected my toes are
wiggling i started breathing on the back
stage here in stream yard
um and uh man i love some of those
practical and powerful tips uh friends
uh i i want to encourage you um colin's
a great dude in general not only just a
world-class businessman but it's been
cool to get to know them and as you know
we only really like to connect and
collaborate with people who we not only
know they're world-class in their
content in
their training in their coaching
materials but also in things like family
and values and so calling i'm really
grateful you're on here and of course
we'll link up your stuff the special
offer at
thinkinfusionselling.com and you can
check out the show notes if you're
listening to this but colin give people
a way to follow you what social accounts
are you most active on and anything you
want the think media podcast community
to know about yeah absolutely so uh
instagram that's kind of like where i am
most active at the moment so you can
just follow me at colin boyd just with
1l colin boyd uh also i do have a
podcast which is called the expert edge
so if you search the expert edge just on
itunes or any podcast that you're
listening to
and my website's colonboyd.com
because there's a countrysinger on.com
and so if you like country songs go
to.com if you want to learn how to speak
more effectively and sell your stuff
without being pushy go to dot co
colin boyd thank you
so good man thanks for having me i
appreciate it sean
well i hope you're ready to start using
your signature story in your content i
love how colin walked through those
three ingredients and how to even get
comfortable on camera sharing that story
it's so important that as you start
creating content as you start putting
yourself out there online and growing
your personal brand that you are giving
people the opportunity to connect with
who you really are i think this is so
important and i really believe it's part
of the reason why you are here listening
to this content because you've heard
maybe a piece of our story or maybe
you're ready to go deeper with
understanding why we think youtube is
important maybe you've connected with
our values or the fact that i'm a mom of
three who homeschools or the fact that
sean's wife almost died and he was able
to step up as a leader and provide for
his family there may be something inside
of these signature stories that
resonates with you and that's why you
are here now if you've never heard any
of those stories i'll make sure to link
up down below some of the talks where
shawn and i have shared a little bit
more of the intimate side of who we are
with you here on the podcast and if you
want to call in to help coach you
through your signature story you can go
over to
thinkinfusionselling.com where he's
sharing the nine strategies that you
need to be attracting the right clients
to your offers again this is if you are
more advanced right if you've already
got something that you're selling or you
know you're going to be selling to a
target audience
this can be right for you so you can go
over to thinkinfusionselling.com
to get started today now here on the
podcast we love those who are rating and
reviewing our show it means the world to
me to be able to get to read what you
are saying about the show how it's
impacting your life and the takeaways
that you're getting every single week so
thank you for those who are rating and
reviewing the podcast this helps other
content creators and entrepreneurs just
like you see that this could be a
podcast that they should be investing
their time in because i know your time
is valuable and it means the world to me
that you would give us this hour this
half hour this 20 minutes depending on
the episode length every single week so
thank you so much for that today comes
from deed delightful one
they said think podcast is necessary
listening i tend to agree if you want
the most relevant and practical
information of how to succeed on youtube
the think podcast is the place to come
it's not boring impractical cookie
cutter information regurgitated for you
to consume the information here is
relatable digestible and strategy based
information that can help you to create
a business on youtube i love that there
is humor real stories and laser focus
methodology to help you not only get
started but dominate on the platform oh
my goodness that is probably one of the
most
impactful reviews that i have read and i
am so grateful that i got to bring that
to you here on the show because i hope
that is exactly what everyone is getting
the fact that this is not boring
impractical but that we're sharing real
life stories of what it's like to be a
content creator bringing awesome guests
like colin to the podcast and helping
you get over your comfort zone so that
you can press record thank you so much
for leaving such a thoughtful review it
means so much to me well i want to thank
you for being a part of what we're doing
subscribe wherever you listen to this
podcast and join us on this journey of
growing your youtube channel with think
media thanks for watching or listening
and we'll catch you in the next episode
bye
[Music]
you